cette année pour remplir sa hotte le
père noël va devoir parcourir plusieurs
kilomètres
premier arrêt saint-arnoult-en-yvelines
c'est ici qu est implanté sentosphère
cette société existe depuis plus de 30
ans elle imagine dans ses locaux des
jeux sensoriels inspiré de la méthode
montessori ou encore des kits de loisirs
créatifs c'est pas uniquement le petit
jeu sur lequel on joue pendant dix
minutes c'est réellement des choses on
va avoir un apprentissage on va avoir et
on est vraiment sur le premier le
principe de faire les choses soi-même de
réaliser des choses on est dans un monde
on va de plus en plus vite c'est aussi
des jeux qui vont prendre leur temps
avec ses boîtes en carton 100%
recyclable sentosphère mise aussi sur
l'écologie une valeur partagée par une
autre société
direction versailles où s'est installée
depuis peu le siège social de nature et
découvertes
depuis sa création en 1990 l'enseigne
s'est spécialisé dans les produits de
bien-être des produits également liés à
la biodiversité
parmi les cadeaux plébiscités cette
année ce nichoirs pour oiseaux ou encore
ces jouets pour les tout petits
et nous avons aussi cette année leur
lancement de notre gamme pour les 0 à 3
ans qui s'appelle gallopin des bois qui
est une gamme devait jouer très
vertueuse
parce que nous n'utilisons que du coton
bio pour les enfants nous utilisons du
bois fsc de forêts gérées durablement et
enfin dieu la peinture sans solvant pour
les plus grands nature et découvertes
mise notamment sur une valeur sûre la
lecture un des coups de coeur en livrent
en ce moment c'est le livre vivre avec
la terre de charles hervé gouyer de la
ferme du bec hellouin qui nous apprend
les grands principes de la permaculture
et qui est un très très beau cadeau à
offrir
[Musique]
depuis 2015 la nostalgie à son royaume à
mouiller c'est ici qu est installée la
société naftal gift points comme ce site
internet propose des articles sur le
thème de la nostalgie des jouets des
bonbons qui nous font voyager dans le
temps
3000 produits sont référencés on voit
souvent dans les tendances les gens qui
créent leur coffret avec plein de petits
bonbons et justement il faut mettre un
jeu d'eau un yes ils vont faire leur
petit coffret pour que les imagine les
personnes retombe en enfance
des coffrets nostalgique proposé entre
30 et 40 euros